quand on veut dire bonjour merci de
répondre à nos questions gérald darmanin
reçoit ce matin les représentants de
policiers et gendarmes qu'est ce que
vous attendez de ce rendez vous bon déjà
il faut le savoir que gérald darmanin il
reçoit pas de tout laisser tous les
représentants syndicaux il en soit les
principaux syndicats de police nous
france police policiers en colère on n'a
pas été invité même si aujourd'hui on
présente quand même quasiment six mille
fonctionnaires
il faut le savoir que nous on n'attend
pas grand-chose qu'on attend c'est des
actes l'a récemment il ya eu une
manifestation au niveau du trocadéro il
faut savoir qu'il ya environ une
centaine de collègues qui ont été
convoqués os des os des ssds pardon pour
répondre à un petit peu un pour répondre
de leurs actes en vue éventuellement
d'une sanction mais c'est ce qui a été
saisi par le préfet l'allemand
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on attend
qu'est ce que les collègues attendent
puisque hier soir encore gt gt en
communication avec des collègues qui est
évoqué ces des actes des actes c'est
quoi c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui on
attend une reconnaissance
on attend une certaine compréhension de
notre métier puisque aujourd'hui on a
l'impression de ne pas être compris on a
toujours ce discours de hiérarchique
ce discours du en même temps vous l'avez
bien rappeler la dans votre petit
reportage c'est emmanuel macron en
l'espace de 18 mois a complètement
changé de discours
c'est à dire que on avait besoin des
forces de l'ordre parce que ils ont
constitué un dernier rempart face à des
manifestations qui étaient quand même
relativement violente durant le
mouvement d'aidé gilet jaune
donc là il fallait soutenir les forces
de l'ordre puisque on avait besoin
d'elle et aujourd'hui on se retrouve un
petit peu la position inverse
on approche de la présidentielle on a un
petit peu cette impression d'abandon des
désavoué
je dirais par clientélisme électoral et
ça pour nous c'est un support vous
parlez du discours justement entre des
syndicats omniprésent sur les chaînes
d'infos et des policiers de plus en plus
bavard sur les réseaux sociaux comment
est-ce que selon vous devrait
s'organiser la parole officiel de la
police aujourd'hui la parole d'officier
de la police est simple vous avez quinze
organisations syndicales au sein de la
police nationale
on va voir je dirais une vue globale sur
les revendications puisque chaque
syndicat défend sa propre ligne et des
porte la parole de ses propres adhérents
aussi aujourd'hui il faudrait que gérald
darmanin aux manuels macro convie tous
les secrétaires généraux de tous les
syndicats de police
on peut pas se contenter de trois
syndicats majoritaires pour essayer
d'éteindre la gronde ou d'éteindre le
feu ça fonctionnera pas ça fonctionnera
pas aujourd'hui avec ce phénomène là on
se rend compte que de plus en plus de
frontières de police s'affranchissent
aussi des syndicats il essaie par eux
mêmes de faire de faire bondir de faire
entendre leur colère de faire entendre
je dirais leur désarroi parce qu'on en
est là aujourd'hui on en est réellement
là tant qu'europe 1 on parle des
syndicats de police mais on peut parler
également de la population selon un
sondage
aujourd'hui opinion way pour 20 minutes
près de la moitié des jeunes n'ont pas
confiance en la police plus des trois
quarts estiment que les violences
policières sont une réalité et près de
la moitié réponse que la police et est
raciste on vient de voir également un
reportage de nadège abderrazak chez
amnesty international qui dénonce un
également des brutalités policières en
augmentation dans son dernier rapport
votre réaction tout ça moi déjà vous ne
ferez pas vous ne ferez pas parler de
violences policières
aujourd'hui moi je vais mettre le poing
sur deux choses on a des manifestations
depuis le début des mouvements sociaux
contre la loi de la sécurité globale qui
on est et où on voit des ponts tient de
police complètement débordés en
parallèle il ya cette dernière
manifestation où on voit clairement que
les forces de l'ordre en pile dessus sur
les manifestations sur les manifestants
tout cas les plus radicaux on a vendu
très peu de casse on a eu très peu de
violence à l'encontre des fonctionnaires
et très peu de violence contre les
manifestants qu'est ce que ça veut dire
pour moi aujourd'hui
le problème c'est pas tant le
fonctionnaire en lui-même on essaie
toujours d'individualiser les fautes
chez eux chez nos collègues mais on
oublie un petit peu le sens du collectif
et institutionnels aujourd'hui on voit
que portent les ordres sont donnés par
les ordres sont claires quand on a déjà
su on a beaucoup moins de problèmes on a
beaucoup moins de problèmes de la part
de
nos collègues qui sont parfois laissés
aussi je dirais un petit peu dans une
improvisation totale mais on a aussi
beaucoup moins de que vous dénoncez des
ordres au dessus gerhard schick mans
c'est ça moi ce que je dénonce
aujourd'hui c'est parfois l'absence
d'ordre
l'absence d'ong qui permet en fait de
s'installer péchés capitaux que gérald
darmanin a évoqué mais vous savez c'est
toujours pareil ça fait des années que
ça dure on parle de problème on fait des
réunions surtout on est toujours en
train de mettre en place des comités ont
peu métier que consultatif et c est tout
ce qu elle résultat aujourd'hui aucun
puisque on préfère traiter les effets du
mécontentement par exemple avec la
convocation des collègues dans
l'antichambre de l'igpn une sanction
plutôt que traiter les causes parce que
les causes c'est qu'aujourd'hui il ya un
réel malaise ça des forces de l'ordre il
ya un réel malaise qui s'installe qui
est de plus en plus présent et comme
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure qui
aujourd'hui est un peu différent c'est
que mais comme on dirait mes fonctions
de police prennent la parole
de même sur les réseaux sociaux de
l'igpn selon le sondage de ce matin 92 %
des jeunes de 18 30 ans interrogées sont
favorables à une réforme de l'igpn la
police des polices
on sait que les affaires zineb redouane
avec l' enquête de dix causes qui
discrédite le rapport officiel des gilet
jaune et borny beaucoup de beaucoup
d'affaires tout cela qu'est ce que vous
pensez
de la réforme de l'igpn justement alors
il faut ça contrairement à ce que la
majorité des gens pensent igpn
ce n'est pas l'ami du policier les gpn
bail en toute indépendance
ils font un travail je dirais sur le
plan administratif aussi pénale l'igpn
aujourd'hui ils n'étaient pas là pour
soutenir les frontières de protides et
là pour faire la lumière sur des
situations précises
suivant les éléments qui vont avoir dans
leur dossier ils pourront donner ou non
suite à une affaire
c'est exactement le même parti que c'est
le même travail que nos enquêteurs sont
si longs les éléments c'est factuel et
pas le fonctionnaire a sanctionné sur le
plan administratif voire pénales et
s'ils n'ont pas les éléments et ben ils
pourront pas poursuivre il ya ce qui est
logique on reste dans un état de droit
dernière question anton villedieu à un
de vos collègues et alexandre langlois
policiers dans les yvelines secrétaire
national du syndicat de police vigie a
récemment demandé à quitter la police
nationale ils dénoncent des suicides au
sein des forces de l'ordre et que le
rôle de la police ne serait non plus
de défendre les libertés du peuple et de
les annihiler votre commentaire sur ces
déclarations
alors moi j'ai les pages n'est pas que
déjà j'aime pas que ton nom de
l'opposition le peuple et la police il
faut savoir que la majorité qui contient
un peu police beaucoup d'affection japon
des gilet jaune et gilet jaune
historique 1 on parle bien de des
revendications de battre donc toujours
mettre en opposition police un peuple
moi ça me pose un réel problème ensuite
peut-être qu'on peut se rejoindre sur
sur un point c'est qu'aujourd'hui on a
un peu que cette police et notre police
en tout cas est dirigée par le politique
c'est le politique aujourd'hui qui
décide des actions en fonction de
l'actualité et en fonction je dirais de
la pression de l'opinion
donc le on a ce policier il de terrain
qui est toujours dans cette urgence
politico médiatique
et ça ça permet pas en fait deux comment
dire de d'avoir un travail très objectif
aujourd'hui le policier doit être au
service du peuple
merci antoine villedieu d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes le secrétaire national du syndicat
france police policiers en colère et
délégué départemental et reines de la
haute saône